[Music]
it was as protests go very upbeat as
dozens of campaigners many of them
children brought their message to
buckingham palace asking the queen to
rewild royal land including
conservationist and broadcaster chris
packham
we're asking politely and passively the
royal family to change their mind we're
not banging on the gates saying oh eu
do this do this do this we're saying
excuse me would you mind thinking about
it
but we do want them to think about it so
underlying all of that uh politeness and
democracy is an urgency as well that's
why these young people have traveled
here today
with a petition carrying more than a
hundred thousand signatures this is a
grassroots movement that's captured the
imagination of young conservationists
when we started it was just like a group
of kids doing something that we enjoyed
and now it's kind of grown into
this i think that they are listening to
this
because they took the petition
and they
and i think i hope that they will
sign it and do it i think they care
about this issue a lot because it
doesn't just affect us it also affects
them in a lot of different ways and it's
really important that everybody cares
about it including the royals
the royals own land across the uk
including roughly 50 000 acres at
balmoral in scotland added altogether
it's equivalent to 1.4 percent of the uk
an area twice the size of greater london
in england the duchy of cornwall alone
owns 130 000 acres giving prince charles
an income of millions of pounds
the royal family does campaign on
conservation last week the heir to the
throne and the queen were filmed
planting trees at balmoral the estate is
currently managed for farming grouse
shooting and deer stalking rewilding
here for example would take the area
back to a natural state reforesting
great slaves of land but rewilding is
not always straightforward there's
concern about the reintroduction of
natural predators such as wolves and
more widely some farmers fear it could
cost them their livelihoods
in a statement the royal estates told us
members of the royal family have a
long-standing commitment to conservation
the royal estates are constantly
evolving and looking for new ways to
continue improving biodiversity
conservation and public access to green
spaces
these campaigners say it's time for the
royal family to stop talking about
conservation
and send their land back to nature where
they say it belongs harriet hadfield sky
news buckingham palace